today we have a frabjous treat for you
this poem is full of seemingly
nonsensical words
that somehow manage to make sense ready
to see if you can follow along
without further ado we present
jabberwocky by lewis carroll
twas brillig and the slythy toves did
gaia
and gimble in the wave all mimsy were
the borogoves
and the murm wraths out grave
beware the jabberwock my son the jaws
that
bite the claws that catch beware the jab
jab
bird and shun the frumious panda snatch
he took his vorpal sword in hand
long time the manxum foe he sought
so rested he by the tum-tum tree
and stood a while in thought
and as in afish thought he stood
the jabberwock with eyes of flame came
whistling through the tulgey wood
and bubbled as it came one
two one two and through and through the
verbal blade went snicker snack
he left it dead and with its head he
went glumping
back
and hast thou slain the jabberwock
come to my arms my beamish boy o
frabjouste luca
he chortled in his joy
it was brilliant and the slidy toves
did gaia and gimble in the wave all
mimsy
were the borogoves and the rats
without grave
[Music]
bye